[Musique]
les essentiels du Sénat
transformer les ressources humaines des
armées
en amont du dépôt du projet de loi de
programmation militaire 2024 à 2030 les
sénateurs Joel guerriot et marie-arlett
Carlotti ont remis un rapport
d'information sur le modèle de
ressources humaines des armées depuis
leur professionnalisation décidé en 1996
les forces armées françaises ont connu
une réduction significative de leurs
effectifs en 25 ans c'est plus de 200
000 postes du ministère des armées qui
ont été supprimées le redressement
progressif récent de ces effectifs
amorcé en réaction aux attaques
terroristes perpétrées sur le territoire
national n'ont pas permis de compenser
la déflation or la dégradation récente
du contexte sécurité renforce la
nécessité de mettre en cohérence le
format de ressources humaines des armées
avec nos ambitions stratégiques
notamment celle de répondre à
l'hypothèse d'un engagement majeur
aussi pour les rapporteurs la prochaine
programmation militaire devra répondre
au défi de l'attractivité dans les
secteurs prioritaires de recrutement de
fidélisation des personnels et de la
transformation des réserves
opérationnelles de premier niveau alors
qu'un nombre croissant de militaires
perçoivent désormais leur passage dans
les forces armées comme une étape parmi
d'autres dans leur parcours
professionnel les rapporteurs estiment
que l'actualisation des grises
indiciaires et la poursuite des efforts
en faveur des familles de militaires
constituent de leviers de fidélisation
les rapporteurs soulignent aussi que les
armées devront mener des efforts
conséquents pour recruter dans les
domaines prioritaires du renseignement
et de la cyberdéfense
la formation initiale dans le domaine
cyber devra être développé et une
trajectoire financière devra être
définie pour limiter les écarts de
rémunération avec le secteur privé enfin
pour les rapporteurs le projet de
doublement des réserves opérationnelles
des armées annoncées par le Président de
la République en juillet 2022 ne pourra
produire ses effets qu'à la condition
d'être accompagnés de moyens budgétaires
adéquats
pour en savoir plus consultez le site
Internet du Sénat
[Musique]